[Music]
now
just like we've been telling you the
democrats defund and dismantle police
agenda
it's real it's scary and it's bringing
chaos not safety to cities across
america but the far left democrats they
themselves
refuse to live under the policies that
they want for the rest of the country
for example squad member congresswoman
corey bush
is a defund the police advocate she
recently reportedly spent
70 000 on private security
and everywhere we see these defund
policies put into place
we see cities that are less safe less
secure and more violent
surprise surprise ask yourself who
is this helping who is enriched by
anti-police policies
it's not working americans it's not the
middle class and it's certainly not
our most vulnerable and struggling
communities
defund the police is now an undeniable
disaster for democrats
and causing undeniable danger all across
the country
joining me now for reaction congressman
madison cawthorne
along with california gubernatorial
candidate and radio talk show host
larry elder gentlemen thank you so much
for joining us tonight on hannity
uh congressman i'm going to start with
you because you have to serve with corey
bush
uh and she's out there yelling screaming
advocating for defund the police
open borders all kinds of things but of
course when it comes to her own
situation you know she just shells out
the tens of thousands of dollars to
have the private armed security
well jason you know i've got a lot of
these antifa people who want to kill me
back in my home
city of asheville and so i've hired
private security before
and let me tell you seventy thousand
dollars over a three month period for
private security
that's a full-on battalion and this
woman
literally ran on the idea that all cops
are bastards ran on the idea of
defunding the police
she praised the st louis city council
for defunding the police tonight what
she called a historic
move but now we're seeing that she wants
you to be unsafe she wants you to not
have firearms to protect yourself
but she wants to be protected this is
the exact same thing as if she's an
arsonist
going around lighting everybody's
buildings on fire but then hiring a fire
truck to follow her to make sure that
she doesn't get burned
now larry you you put your hat in the
ring to run for governor of california
and
wish you all the best in in the world um
look i
i i wrote a i wrote an opinion piece for
foxnews.com that's up right now
and it's it shows the statistics and the
numbers that are just
undeniable in these democrat-run cities
uh
and states and the huge massive
surge of of crime that's happening in
places like california where they try to
defund the police
and they don't know how to control the
the the criminal population
what would you do what do you think
should be the right public policy well
that's why jason i'm running and i urge
people to go to elector.com
let's remember corey bush tweeted on
july 4th
that black people aren't really free i
guess she was talking about her city of
saint louis it is 45
black but it is estimated that of the
roughly 300 murders last year
90 of them black on black this is the
highest murder rate in st
louis in 50 years now when she says she
wants to defund the police she means she
wants you to defund
your police not her police we talk about
chicago often being the murder capital
of the world
jason's st louis murder rate is three
times higher
than that of of of chicago and she's
talking about defunding the police
it's absolutely outrageous the people
are most likely to be hurt
by this are the black and brown people
that the left claims that they care
about so deeply
now congressman there was precision
policing
in new york back in the day where rudy
giuliani bernie carrick others
look if you dropped a turnstile they'd
come after you you broke a window they'd
come after you but now
in so many these other states and cities
they have
raised the level where allowing for
petty theft and for shoplifting
they don't even try to arrest you
anymore
oh you know it's absolutely ridiculous
you want to hear a shocking statistics
jason
the number of shootings that happened
last year in 2020 in new york city were
up
94 now everyone that knows that the
murder our murders are up over this year
and last year by about 4 000 people
but that actually obscures one of the
most important facts about that
statistic
and it's that these murder increases are
happening in blue run
cities places like whether it's
washington d.c new york city or out in
l.a the murder rates are up in an
incredible amount i believe it's the
reason we see new york and california
losing congressional seats
and them coming to places like texas and
florida because people realize they
cannot raise a family
in what is essentially a war zone these
people continue to push for
this police reform that makes people
more endangered and makes our
communities
less safe they they say one thing with
one with their words and do it
completely other with their actions
yeah it's unbelievable in new york city
they took 500 undercover policemen
off the streets larry that isn't going
to make the city in new york any safer
the number one job of government is to
protect people and property the number
one issue californians are concerned
about
is crime crime up violent crime up in
san francisco
up in san diego up in los angeles as
defund the police
have diverted 150 million dollars from
the lapd fund
uh lapd budget uh for youth programs and
they're not doing the number one job
facing uh the the country again i urge
people to go to
elect elder.com if you want to turn this
puppy around elect elder.com
man i think you've got that in like five
times so congratulations
larry thank you so much congratulations
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else